we've seen two different types of
reforms being pushed to fix the
curriculum disagreements in the
government school system and one has
been from the top down to ban CRT for
example or other Concepts that are
divisive Concepts which one doesn't
actually work because it's a basically a
form of playing whack-a-mole where
you're trying to hit the mole and the
mold doesn't actually go down it doesn't
work it's unenforceable we have videos
from all these States from Texas from
Idaho from Tennessee from Iowa and
others where you have undercover
journalists going there from accuracy
and media and getting the public school
officials to admit that yeah we banned
it here but we'd still do it we just
call it social emotional learning or we
call it student mental health so they
just move the goal posts and it's
totally unenforceable for the most part
and the better solution in in my view is
from the bottom up with school choice
it's like if if you're just not going to
listen to what the law says anyway and
if it's really hard to if we can't even
agree on what critical race Theory even
means and it means different things to
different parents um they parents know
like the specific things that they want
and what they do not want taught and the
better way is to just give the money to
the parents in the form of an education
savings account and let them choose the
school that best aligns with their
values I think this is the only way
forward through Freedom as opposed to
force so that families can choose the
schools that that align with their
values and meet their needs in other
ways the whole government school system
is inherently in conflict with our view
of what education should look like which
is parents raising kids in ways that
that they want to you can't do that what
they one size fits all government School
Monopoly it is by definition never going
to work you're always going to have one
group of parents forcing their views on
another group of parents it's typically
a majority or in some cases a special
interest minority inflicting their views
on other groups and that is a problem
and the only way out is is through
allowing parents to choose DeSantis the
governor of Florida leading you know
candidate possibly for the Republican
nomination for president is a kind of
fascinating case study Florida has a
robust school choice program that he has
been adding to it existed before him but
he has added it but he's also Going
Hammer and Tong after certain specific
aspects not just with the K-12 education
but has also tried to do that at the um
at the college and or post-secondary
level how do you how do you feel about
somebody like a DeSantis something
similar I guess is going on in a place
like Texas uh with Greg Abbott where
Texas you know oddly has not been a
leader in school choice despite you know
being a conservative state but you know
what do you make of somebody like a
DeSantis is is this
um you know is this just an internal
contradiction that will have to explode
or you know what what do you what do you
have to say about somebody like a
DeSantis I think that the example Corey
used earlier of political whack-a-mole
is instructive here right when you're a
hammer everything looks like a nail when
you're a big you know Mallet everything
looks like a mole and a whack-a-mole
game and someone like the santis who is
seeking higher office and trying to uh
illustrate his kind of distinctions from
Trump and other candidates on the the
field uh is leaning into this moment
when as Corey pointed out a lot of these
parents are upset they're going to
school board meetings they're trying to
to fight back so I think it's
politically strategic on his part to be
kind of the tip of the spear in fighting
some of this through the political
process where others are just trying to
show up to school board meetings and
pressure elected officials he is one and
he has a bully pulpit and he can do
something about it at the end of the day
uh what DeSantis is doing and other
efforts like this through the political
process to uh to restrict teachers to
modify curriculum to tie the hands of
local Educators in the teachers unions
number one it's it's only going to go so
far as Corey pointed out they're going
to wiggle around it and find a way
around it so it looks good superficially
for DeSantis to enact these controls or
others like him but when the rubber
meets the road are we really having the
substantive changes that were you know
purported to happen when the law was
passed or the executive order was signed
fundamentally I think of the Henry David
Thoreau quote that there are for every
thousand hacking at the at the branches
there's only one striking at the root
and we've been here before we've been
here with common core we've been here
with social emotional learning we've
been here critical race Theory and now
all this you know gender Wars and many
other things in the decades preceding
the examples I listed and where has that
gotten us where have the substantive
reforms been nothing is going to happen
until we strike the root the root as I
perceive it and I think Corey agrees is
the Monopoly is the guaranteed uh
consumer pipeline to the government
school system and until we introduced
substantial competitive forces to induce
enough market pressure on these
institutions to reform none of these
topical marginal uh efforts are going to
have substantive change they might make
us feel good in the moment we'll all
applaud at a press conference when the
new reform is announced but you know
months later when the dust settles and
people's attention moves on to the next
topic and everyone forgets about it all
the people who are still there all the
teachers union members all the
administrators are going to be
continuing to do what they want to do
and uh and we're just going to further
slide into mediocrity I want to
introduce a quote from Robert pondicio
who said uh AEI as we wrote this for the
uh Fordham Institute but it's
provocative and I want to get your uh
your reaction to this there is an idea
especially prevalent among Libertarians
and some conservatives that school
choice is the answer to the problems of
social justice activism and political
indoctrination in schools because it
allows parents to pull their children
out of schools where woke ideology has
infused the curriculum and school
culture the idea is not just wrong or
simplistic it's dangerous
um my question because you've touched on
this about how
um you know a lot of uh you know the
attempts of some of this stuff are is
whack-a-mole but I guess my question uh
for you guys is
um
the issue of
um kind of community where does common
culture go in this debate because it
seems like America is desperate for some
kind of commonality but school choice
which I certainly support exactly in the
way you guys are talking about it would
lead in a different direction more of a
of a kind of uh vulcanized experience
yeah go ahead yeah
so we don't have we don't have it we
have nine out of 10 kids in public
schools today and we have a extremely
divided uh country today and politically
polarized country so the you know
there's kind of this fairy tale
um theory of the democratic Pro public
yeah the public schools were The
Crucible uh yeah I mean Milton Friedman
used to talk about this it was a product
of public schools in the 1920s and 30s
and he would often talk about that uh
that goes back to that a kind of
Americanization model which may or may
not have worked
um but it was certainly is not where
we're at now and overwhelmingly the
studies find that private school choice
in particular leads to more better Civic
outcomes including tolerance of others
views which I think is a really
important one more political
participation uh and other Civic
outcomes as well so the evidence doesn't
bear out the theories that are laid out
by the the government School Defenders
yeah uh yeah so I I recently had the
opportunity to go back to my old
stomping grounds where I went to high
school I grew up in San Diego and uh and
I went to the high school and it was a
very sad experience what before was an
open set of buildings and free-flowing
student body was under lock and key
there were Gates everywhere cameras
metal detectors and all the rest and and
that school is not an anomaly especially
with all the school shootings so many
people want to further turn these into
prison-like institutions so to your
question about community and culture I
question whether a statist institution
such as Government schools is really
going to enhance our community build
community enhance the culture build the
social fabric I think quite the opposite
I think the state is on one end of the
spectrum and true Society is on the
other we need voluntary relationships
and so forth to be able to rebuild that
and as a long time homeschooling dad I
only put my kids in that micro school
this past fall we've been homeschooling
them for a decade and of course early on
we would get the critiques like you
sometimes hear oh your kids aren't going
to be socialized they're you know
they're not going to be part of the
community and then I look at what how
kids on on you know with all the book
like on in the government schools The
Bullying the toxicity pornography drugs
cheating and all the rest and I'm like
that's not how I want my kids to be
socialized when my kids are out doing
field trips in the middle of the day
while all their public school peers are
sitting in a box box in a brick and
mortar cage my kids are out there
connecting with adults shopping at
businesses going through museums
connecting with other families there's
very strong community and I think that
through this kind of decentralized
educational Marketplace if we can
continue to grow and sustain it we're
going to have a far richer and more
tightly interwoven social fabric of true
Community than we do right now with
everyone just sitting in these Factory
schools across the country being
propagandized by leftist public school
teachers that was an excerpt from
reasons live stream with Corey DeAngelis
and Conor boyak the authors of
mediocrity 40 ways government schools
are failing today's students if you want
to see the full conversation go here if
you want to see another excerpt go here
and make sure to come back next Thursday
every Thursday at 1 pm eastern time when
Zach weismiller and I are doing a live
stream with somebody very interesting
that you are definitely going to want to
know